zeno writing in do you think there's
such a thing as bad publicity I
understand media attention can be very
helpful but you think there are ways in
which it can hurt things you would want
to avoid so I do think there is such
thing as bad publicity now do you think
that there are ways that it can hurt the
immediate example that comes to mind for
me is Donald Trump right so a lot of
what we're seeing right now from him
yeah he's all over the place he's kind
of dominating the news coverage in terms
of the election right now but a lot of
people are also picking up on and
pointing out the fact that some of these
comments you know can be offensive or
they rub people the wrong way and he's
consistently doing it a time after time
after time and so a lot of people are
saying and thinking that this is
eventually going to hurt him and so it's
great that there is you know a lot of
media coverage that he's getting but
consistently you know of sending people
and things like that now don't get me
wrong you got to take a stand on things
and media people like that but when you
kind of cross that line where you're no
longer respectful to people and doing
that consistently I think you run into
issues where you know it could be
detrimental instead of actually helping
you so that's just one example that came
to mind for me when I saw that question
yeah I have I have mixed feelings on it
um you know I wonder if you asked Donald
Trump you know what he would feel like
is that hurting his brand or not because
he is getting an insane amount of
coverage and I'm sure a lot of people
now hate him because of it but then do
people the to his supporters people feel
the same way now love him and get more
exposure because of it I don't know I'm
on the fence the one the idea that came
to my mind was Rob Ford who was our
mayor of toronto I don't know if you the
name means anything to do but he did a
whole bunch of kind of really stupid
things in the media and and it put
Toronto on the map for a while in the US
and yet there's a lot of times you know
Canadian stuff isn't covered that much
but it was in a negative way right it
wasn't it wasn't put it in a positive
light and I was just hearing yesterday
on the radio talking about the Blue Jay
game we're in the next round go jays go
and there's
still referencing Rob Ford like all
Toronto is known for is the Blue Jays
now and and Rob Ford and I love my city
and its kind of I feel like it's an it's
a stain as much as he put it on the map
it's also put on him up a negative way
so I don't know I I have mixed feelings
on it I don't have a great answer on
that but yeah I mean because it is you
kind of never know how it's going to
shake down and so to your point about
Trump it could well select the wait and
see right if it's either going to hurt
him or if it's going to help him but in
your case like the example that you were
given that you were giving your right
you know once something like that
happens it's kind of hard to separate
yourself from that once that bad news is
out there so to the question of whether
or not media coverage can in some way
have the potential to be a bad thing it
can because they can almost tattoo your
brain for people with your brand is so I
think it can be a detrimental thing yeah
I think so in terms of what's the advice
like so there's the question but then
what's what's the advice that you would
give to an entrepreneur around that
around just avoiding or cuz I mean you I
don't have an easy answer for how to
avoid it because I guess that on the one
hand um you don't necessarily want to
play everything safe you have to take a
stand right so I guess my advice is
almost what you were saying before of
know who you are and stay true to who
you are don't do something just for the
sake of trying to get publicity or
because you know it's going to be
controversial and get everybody's eyes
on you if that's not who you are then I
would say don't do it so identify who
you are what you want to be known for
and stick to that and just tell your
story yeah so like would you give Trump
advice to like to tone down to say
listen dude you're going off the deep
end I think with Trump is that yeah he
let us who he is but my advice to him is
to tone it down and to consider the fact
that listen you know you're running for
presidency and especially for a title
for a position like that right we're
talking about an entire country where
the votes that you want this is that
diverse set of people so offending
people rubbing people the wrong way you
got to kind of take it easy so
yeah I would just advise that he tones
it down just a little just the look
alright cool interesting just